hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt viele von euch fragen mich immer wo
ich einkaufen gehe und wie unser einkauf
dann auch so aussieht also damit kennt
und auch schon von anfang an verfolgt
der weiß natürlich dass ich vieles beim
globus einkaufe das ist ein ganz großer
supermarkt bei uns hier in waghäusel und
den kenne ich schon seit meiner kindheit
denn ich war auch schon meinen eltern
immer dort und meine schwester hat zum
beispiel dort gearbeitet die andere
übrigens auch also beide schwester mein
bruder hat schon dort gearbeitet und ich
wollte als kind auch ein zimmer dort
arbeiten hat sie natürlich alles wisse
land entwickelt und ich hab nicht dort
gearbeitet aber auf jeden fall kaufe ich
halt immer noch meine sachen dort ein
aber ich kaufe natürlich nicht alles
dort also ich versuche auch immer bei
uns hier im kleinen ort im ortsteil nach
einzukaufen weil ich es einfach sehr
wichtig findet dass man die einzelnen da
vor ort auch unterstützt denn nicht
jeder ist mobil und nicht jeder kommt
auch rausgefahren im auto und ich finde
es aber ganz wichtig dass man im ort
darin immer ganz viele kleine läden hat
die man eben auch zum beispiel zu fuß
erreichen kann
nein ich konnte nicht sagen weil dein
bruder nicht gefeuert
nein nicht ok wack schuldigen ja auf
jeden fall zeige ich euch jetzt erst
einmal zwei meiner lieblings leben bei
uns im ortsteil keller und später zeige
ich euch noch den globus also der erste
laden in denen ich immer ganz gerne gehe
das ist ein kleiderladen für kinder und
für die sich vom säuglings bis
jugendalter kanada klamotten finden und
auch accessoires fürs kinderzimmer zum
beispiel und der laden heißt ebel und
kreta
die inhaberin ist die jessy und sie hat
den laden auch nach den beiden kindern
benannt also eher sohn heißt eben und
die tochter ist greta und in dem laden
findet man wirklich alles und es gibt
halt auch klamotten und kleine schöne
dinge die sonst eigentlich nirgends gibt
und die einfach richtig hübsch sind und
in dem laden da wird man immer ganz gut
beraten gibt es damit dabei oder ihre
mutter arbeitet auch dort und da kann
man eben hingehen ist wirklich ganz
schön schnuckelig und richtig toll
eingerichtet also ich finde es sieht
immer so aus wir sind ein kleines
kinderzimmer ein kunterbuntes auch ein
teppich ausgelegt und es sind ganz viele
spielsachen mit dabei und kuscheltiere
und da ist es doch immer ganz schön
einzukaufen schönste der schönen machen
die seen schafft individuelle läden über
wenn heutzutage in den innenstädten rein
gehst ist irgendwie alles immer gleich
alles auf einmal die gleichen lebt so
ist ob er nach frankfurt geht sondern
stuttgart die innenstadt ist gleich was
die kleinen läden sind die immer die
gleichen konzerne und dass sich solche
kleinen läden machen eben jede stadt
individuell und vor allem schön bunt vor
allem wenn wir hier dann zweimal im jahr
verkaufsoffenen sonntag haben dann haben
eben auch die ganz schönen kleinen läden
offen und das ist dann immer toll wenn
man dahin laufen kann und dann ist man
ein bisserl was und trinkt bisher was
zusammen verbringt der mittag zusammen
und das finde ich immer richtig schön
man kennt man kennt die inhaber mal und
ich hab sie innerhalb durch die einkäufe
main belegte innenstadt wenn du
heutzutage die innenstädte anguckt oder
auch bei uns inzwischen jetzt auch schon
sehr sehr viel aber verloren was haben
wir bestimmt es gibt 44 sportwetten
leben
dann geht es dann 10 dönerläden ist ein
schlimmes aber es ist einfach diese
schönen stelle wie genial mehr kaputt
weil einfach sich das kaufverhalten zu
extrem verändert genau also keineswegs
mittlerweile alles im internet bestellen
und bekommt alles nach hause geliefert
wir haben ja auch einen onlineshop aber
ich versuche trotzdem immer alles vor
ort zu kaufen also ich versuche immer
die einzelhändler vor ort zu
unterstützen
und genau sondern kleine laden haben wir
auch noch in kirrlach und zwar ist es
ein kleiner supermarkt da bekommt man
zum beispiel in bern haben häufig mit
dem rad sagt immer dass es am
tante-emma-laden nur auf das handtor
laden genau
und das schöne ist da bekommt man
wirklich ganz ganz sachen ganz neue
spezialitäten wo man nicht überall
bekommen aber auch zb unseren türkischen
tee holen wir immer genau oder kohle hat
auch immer finde ich wunderschöne immer
morgens bis abends geöffnet die viele
ältere leute die kein auto haben gehen
einkaufen genau die müssen auch
einkaufen weil sie die möglichkeiten
haben wir werden auch mal alle älter und
damit auch das problem hat vielleicht
nicht mehr zum einkaufen fahren können
und ich finde es einfach schön wenn man
solche läden noch unterstützt und dort
noch einkauft und was auch noch ganz
wichtig ist wenn ich wissen zum beispiel
einfach weiterreden
meyer ich bin mehreren vereinen und es
ist auch immer schön wenn man so ein
verein hat und mal zu diesen legen geht
kann man die lesen und nach sponsoren zu
fünf eier oder so da sind meistens diese
läden auch bereit ein sponsoring zu
machen und zu helfen und wie zeichnet
auch schöne gebäude zu kennen und diese
leute in der innenstadt zu unterstützen
ganz ganz wichtig geht ihre innenstädte
einkaufen und laster auch mal geld
liegen das ist ganz wichtig viele leute
und ja wenn ich auch wichtig also so
viele jetzt zum thema innenstadt
natürlich gibt's viel mehr schöne kleine
leben ich hätte auch gerne alle gezeigt
aber dann würdest du video einfach viel
zu lange geworden also wenn jetzt noch
sehen wollt kann ich euch gerne zeigen
ansonsten müsste einfach nachkommen und
die innenstadt einfach selber angucken
oder machst du gerade schleichwerbung
für ja unser ort ist schön und jetzt
zeige ich euch den globus und zwar habe
ich beim globus immer so eine bestimmte
einkaufstour und da gehen wir erst mal
hin
wer kennt es nicht man steht direkt vom
einkaufswagen braucht einen chip und hat
keinen in der tasche und hier braucht
man das einfach nicht
man kann den einkaufswagen direkt ohne
job und ohne mädchen nehmen
wir schaffen uns rein kommst du meistens
oben oben ist der non-food-bereich da
geht dann verschiedene bereiche die
haushaltswaren drogerie abteilung da
gibt's autozubehör kleidung schuhe und
zum beispiel auch bücher
die in der küchenabteilung finde ich
ganz gemütlich denn man kann sich hier
die bücher aussuchen kann sich hier ganz
gemütlich in die ecke selbst da vorne
geht es noch warme getränke kaffee und
wasser und dann kann man hier einfach
mal in den büchern blättern
jetzt so richtig große
spielwarenabteilung und was ich hier
richtig genial finde da gibt's diese
geburtstags kisten die kammer dann mit
dem kind zusammen führen also mit dem
geburtstagskind kann man alles rein tun
was ich das kind wünscht oder was die
eltern sich wünschen und dann dürfen die
gäste hier an die geburtstagsgäste die
steht dann bis zum tag den man eben
darauf schreibt dann weiß man immer was
wünscht sich das kind und was kann ich
schenken
hier in der fotoabteilung gibt natürlich
die fotos zum mitnehmen oder zum
bestellen aber es gibt auch ganz tolle
geschenk möglichkeiten wie zum beispiel
aus dem 3d theater gibt an die figuren
die man gerne möchte
oder wie hier diese essbaren aufleger
die gibt's einmal hier für die
schokolade und einmal als trotten
aufleger
wenn wir oben dann unsere einkauf
erledigt haben fahren wir mit der
rolltreppe runter und gehen direkt zum
eingangsbereich denn da ist sie globus
bäckerei man kann ihn nicht nur seine
produkte den kaufen sondern auch direkt
hier schneiden hier zu hause
hier in der großbäckerei wird er
wirklich alles selbst gebacken das wird
man auch sofort wenn man ins haus rein
läuft denn die bäckerei ist direkt am
eingang der verlust auf frisch
gebackenes brot und brötchen frisch
zeige ich jetzt ein bisschen die
produktion
in der großbäckerei da wird wirklich
alles vor ort selbst gebacken also nicht
aufgeboten
wir sind auch gebacken sondern wirklich
selbst gebacken da weder teig zubereitet
das ein ganz große mail sie los und dann
werden brot brötchen baguettes und
wirklich alles gebacken also auch süße
teile da gibt es alles von a bis z
und da war ich dann auch in der
produktion kurz mit dabei und hab da
brötchen gewendet dann habe ich noch ein
sauerteigbrot war das glaube ich
geformt und in diese kerbe rheingau
nicht du bist ja gar nicht was es ist ja
so dachte schon das wäre irgendwie man
muss wirklich alles aber es waren sogar
kappe da bekommt das brot die schöne
form und dann wird es noch mal auf einem
blech besteuerung dann so gebacken als
richtig toll das ist wirklich alles
handarbeit und wenn man als kunde sich
fragt oder gerne auch mal hinter die
kulissen schauen möchte kann man sich
zum beispiel auch beim gläsernen globus
anmelden und kann dann einfach so bisher
die produktion anschauen also da sind
dann das ist eine kleine entenfamilie
läuft an einer vorne heraus und die
anderen laufen hinterher dann geht man
die bäckerei in die metzgerei und
grillstation in der max laufen in der
aids bereit zum beispiel waren sie auch
vieles eric 80 wusste ob machen heute
machen sie komplett selber und es ist ja
das geniale dass das dass man wohne so
groß ist noch alles selber macht und bin
ich glaube insgesamt schaffen 600
mitarbeiter in diesem globus viele aus
mord das heißt viele arbeitsplätze und
ich finde es toll wenn sven erwins
betrieb wieder viele arbeitsplätze hat
das heißt viele menschen bei lohn und
brot und wenn sie doch fair bezahlen
kann man es nur in unterstützen einfach
das genial ist wirklich die machen
wirklich alles selber man gibt eben auch
eine richtig tolle käsetheke wo es
wirklich alle käsesorten gibt die man
glaub ich kennt die fisch abteilung
finde ich ganz toll die sanierer möchte
zum beispiel hin weil sie immer an fisch
essen möchte
und der liegt er da auch schön frisch
und man darf immer problemlos ist also
wir probieren uns auch immer erst mal
durch und dann können wir immer neue
sachen austesten und wenn es uns später
nehmen was eben genau das heißt es bei
uns immer so ein ding ein produkt muss
immer ganz neu seien
genauso nicht jedes mal wenn manchmal
sind auch in eine und können dass immer
alles probieren
aber wir versuchen wirklich jetzt mal
was neues zu entdecken und ein neues
produkt zu entdecken und das nehmen wir
dann auch mit genau da gibt es ja dann
auch die defa kostet genau vor sich und
stände geben wo man sagt immer im globus
ist es ein bis zwei schläge zeigt
täglich wurde dann sachen verköstigen
kannst ausprobieren kannst neue
geschmacksrichtung von irgendwas und das
ist auch sein erlebnis mal getränke oder
was zu essen
man muss sich alles mögen aber aber es
ist einfach ein erlebnis mal alles
ausprobieren das ist genial an der
geschichte die obst und gemüseabteilung
ist sehr groß da bekommt man zum
beispiel auch exotische früchte und da
ist auch die sushi bar mit dabei das
sushi was hier vorne in der auslage
liegt es wird alles ganz frisch
zubereitet vor allem vor den augen der
kunden und die kunden können das dann
hier vorne ganz fesch mitnehmen oder
auch zu hause selber nachmachen die
zutaten liegen hier auch aus und es wird
immer nur danach gemacht wenn es da
vorne etwas leerer wird das heißt nicht
immer wirklich ganz ganz frisch gemacht
und ich gucke jetzt ein bisschen zu
in der gemüseabteilung gibt zum beispiel
auch von der salatbar da gibt's dann
antipasti und frische salate und dann
kann man sich die salate auch selber
zusammenstellen fürs mittagessen oder
für den snack zwischendurch will ich
auch ganz schön und in der abstimmung
abteilung arbeitet auch meine cousine
die flüchten wenn wir mit der kamera
kommt deswegen sieht man es auch nie vor
der kamera und wenn man sich sieht dann
wird es ganz ganz lange einkauf immer
lange eingabe also eigentlich würdet der
einkauf vielleicht eine halbe stunde
dauern aber ich bin immer zweieinhalb
stunden ungefähr jeder schon mal trifft
hat auch immer irgend jemanden dem man
kennt und dann ist immer schön und ich
glaube mit meiner cousine treffe ich
mich gerade sowieso nur noch bei der
arbeit
und dann treffen wir auch immer unsere
zuschauer dort und dann redet man halt
immer ein bisschen und ja es geht dann
halt immer ein bisschen länger aber es
macht immer spaß und mittlerweile planen
wären auch die zeit ein von david safier
tagesmütter kennen sie auch und dem
globus ist auch so dank gibt es überall
info karten wie jetzt zum beispiel hier
bei den tomaten da steht dann das
tomaten einmaleins und man kann so ein
bisschen was über verschiedene sorten
herausfinden bei den kräutern gibt es
auch erneut größer so genau man kann
immer lesen war woher das produkt kommt
genau was man nicht machen kann erzählte
sind da stand sie in kochbananen gibt es
ja auch weil du meine ich wusste ich
dass das kochen probiert aber es geht
eigentlich mit dabei ich habe mich dann
beschwerten dass sie das die band
kapuziner vorzug plan
das war ja wirklich als der raffinerie
ist schön weil man immer über gewisse
produkte eben auch informiert wird
hier am regal hatten eine richtig große
auswahl man kann nämlich erscheint
nämlich die eier ausgestaltung hier gibt
es auch regionale anbieter
und da gibt es einfach für jeden masse
man kann selber entscheiden welche eier
aus welcher haltungsform nämlich hier
finde ich hier an den kassen und da kann
man immer entscheiden welche kasse geht
es gibt hier die barrierefreien kassen
da kann man zum beispiel mit dem
rollstuhl ganz gut durchfahren es gibt
so wie hier jetzt die hohen kassen da
muss man sich nicht so weit runter
drücken
es gibt süßwaren freie kassen das heißt
man kommt da nicht in versuchung noch
was süßes mitzunehmen so wie es oft
woanders zerfall ist und es gibt hier
die express um einfach ohne
einkaufswagen schnelldurchgang was ich
an den kassen so toll findet da gibt es
keine plastiktüten mehr da haben die
kassen wirklich komplett auf papiertüten
oder auf diese permanent tragtaschen
umgestiegen und ich finde super weil
solche typen die brauchen ja wirklich
ewig um abgebaut zu werden gebaut zu
werden wie viel über 450 jahre
aber da ich das selber noch nicht erlebt
habe 50 jahre braucht wirklich mit julia
abgebaut ist
und ich glaube simon bankengesetz
rausbringen dass sie wirklich inhalt
verboten werden
solange der gesetzgeber noch nichts tut
weh sagt super vorbildlich wenn im
supermarkt sagt wir machen das jetzt ein
bisschen aufstellen das ist auch super
ich bin auch plastiktüten gehören
verboten
und man kann sich damit diese permanent
tragen kann nur meine zeigen
doch komme ich zeit immer gesagt ich
habe da eine
morax asche
genau das ist meine musik passt eine wo
ich gerne benutzt daran erkennt man mich
an dieser tüte im bloß in diesem fall
also das war nicht so ein paar gründe
woran ihr vielleicht erkennen können
warum ich gerne zum globus einkaufen
gehe wie gesagt einmal weil ich schon
immer mit meinen eltern dort war und
weil meine familie dort gearbeitet hat
und einfach weil ich super finde also
ich finde immer alles ist sehr
übersichtlich und ich finde einfach die
einstellung auf super vor allem ist ein
familienunternehmen aus wenn ich weiß
ich auch dass familien nehmen weil das
heißt viele arbeitsplätze macht alles
selber und vor allem auch diese
regionale unterstützt wie man sich
selber noch erinnern wenn du mein
sponsor gebraucht hat er wird ist mehr
ein globus genau also mit unserem
turnverein damals oder auch so also
jeder verein kann eigentlich zum globus
und man wird immer gesprochen weil es
sich einfach für die region einst so ist
es also es nicht da wo wohnen globus
magstadt er ist tun hier ist es
regionale diese soziale versorgung nach
nehmen und vor allem wie sie merkel sind
alle die zentral gesteuert das heißt
wenn ich weiß was es heißt der globus
hatten inhaber geschäftsführer und der
wohl am meisten sind ort das ist
meistens so und selber entscheiden und
er entscheidet dann selber das heißt der
stadt wie die region zuständig kennen
darf da auch selber entscheiden was in
den markt aufnimmt
da kann man als bauern gehen oder als
als erzeuger da gibt's ja auch die
ganzen produkte aus der region und die
firmen aus der region werden unterstützt
und dürfen sich dort eben auch
präsentieren genauso wie deine freundin
ihre mama die machtkämpfe um die
hilflose genau so ähnlich echt super ja
und das sind so die gründe und jetzt
möchte ich euch noch von einer aktion
erzählen und zwar habe ich ja schon
öfter mal im globus wiesental auch eine
back aktion gemacht
das kam einfach so zustande ich war vor
zwei jahren damals angerufen und wollte
damit einem fernsehteam drehen
die wollten irgendwie einfach nur filmen
wie ich einkauf und wo ich einkaufe und
ich hab dann eben erzählt dass ich hat
beim globus einkaufe und wir wollten
dieses dort filmen dann habe ich da beim
geschäftsführer angerufen und habe das
im vorgestellt und er hat dann gleich
meine videos angeschaut und hat gesagt
ja natürlich sehr dürftige filmen und
das wäre dann auch direkt der nächste
tag gewesen und da hat der fernseher
noch nicht zurückgerufen hat gemeint wir
dürfen das jetzt doch nicht machen weil
nämlich dass sponsor dieser
fernsehsendung ein anderer supermarkt
war und sp hat dann die konkurrenz
und dann musste ich praktisch wieder
beim globus absagen was mir natürlich
sehr peinlich und unangenehm war und bin
dann auch persönlich hin zum absagen und
dann hat aber direkt gesagt das ist
nicht schlimm und man kann ja so mal
vielleicht eine aktion machen und so kam
eine erste back aktion verstanden die
war nämlich im april vor drei jahren
denn das könnte bei youtube anschauen
und genau und damals habe ich sogar mein
allererstes autogramm gegeben weil ich
habe neulich überlegt wo wartest das war
im globus bei dieser backaktion das war
im april unter standen drei mädels tat
die haben irgendwie schon eine halbe
stunde vorher gewartet und mit den drei
habe ich ein foto gemacht zwar echt süß
und so kam neben der kontakt von mir mit
globus zustande
und ich hab dann auch mal eine
weihnachtsaktion gemacht da habe ich mit
kindern gebacken das war kostenlos für
alle kinder und wir haben spenden
gesammelt fürs kinderhospiz in mannheim
und so weiter also so kam leider aber
auch gesammelt die jungen damen arbeit
zustande genau für die leider haben wir
dort eine spendenbox aufgestellt mit uns
gemeinsam mit globus überlegt was
könnten wir für meine zuschauer machen
auch deutschlandweit also jetzt nicht
nur im markt in wiesental sondern etwas
wahr wovon ihr alle etwas habt und haben
jetzt eine aktion gestartet und zwar
heißt die backen mit globus und berlin
wie habt ihr vielleicht schon gesehen
auf instagram oder auf facebook da hab
ich schon posting macht und zwar habe
ich rezepte kreiert für globus und die
werden jetzt alle zwei wochen online
auf dem youtube kanal von globus
ausgestrahlt oder aufbacken mit globus
de und das sind backrezepte also meist
kuchen und torten mal was herzhaftes vor
ist auch regionale sache und saisonales
sachen und eben
dessen entsprechend sowie muttertag zum
beispiel oder weihnachten und zum
schulanfang gibt's dann auch rezepte und
diese rezepte gibt es dann einmal online
als video
die gibt's natürlich auch online zum
nachlesen aber die gibt es hierfür in
diesem ordner und zwar bekommt ihr
diesen ordner kostenlos an der
information im globus als in jedem
globus markt in deutschland und stark
jetzt die rezeptkarten noch dafür
und die gibt es dann eben alle zwei
wochen also immer zu einem neuen rezept
gibt es eine neue rezept karte
die könnt ihr euch dann direkt am backen
mit globus und sally regal mitnehmen
sehen sie den oscar zu zeigen dass es
rezept das alle zutaten und die zutaten
befinden sich alle in diesem regal genau
also vorne an der info at was ich einmal
den ordner ab dann in der buck abteilung
bei unsicher setzung das regal steht bei
uns in der buck abteilung in diesem tag
und da gibts da ein großes sally rica
mit allen produkten die ich verwendet
habe und mit der rezept karte also falls
ihr da gerne die rezepte verfolgung
wollt könnt ihr bei mir auf meiner seite
natürlich schauen aber ihr könnt auch
auf der facebook-seite von globus
vorbeischauen da wird es natürlich auch
alles immer gepostet und auf den youtube
kanal von globus werden wird dann eben
alles online gestellt ja ich glaube das
war es so und viele haben natürlich
schon geschrieben und gefragt wo ist den
nächsten globus markt in der nähe gibt
da könnt ihr auch online auf logos de
schaut und einfach bei euch in der nähe
den globus markt suchen werde ich am
nächsten ist als 147 märkten in ganz
deutschland und 100 baumärkte glaube ich
bei den baumärkten ist also nicht in
einem baumarkt in den in das bak regal
gehen werde wahrscheinlich nichts finden
ja also dann hoffe ich dass euch diese
aktion gefällt ich finde auf jeden fall
sehr schön und wir sind auch richtig
tolle rezepte eingefallen und ich habe
ganz viele richtig schöne rezepte
kreiert für euch ja das war's eigentlich
oder und das erste rezept läuft schon
seit dem 18
april das heißt da kann man sich die
karte aktuell abholen und das zweite
rezept kommt dann zwei wochen später
genau alle zwei wochen genau und also
viel spaß jetzt mal beim nachhaken und
ja schön viel spaß hatten und am
nächsten mal geht nicht fort kauf
sie müssten nach links rutschen links ab
1 mein links als rechts geht auf ihn
zurück
denn auch draußen also schön danke aber
was war mit dem doppelkinn okay auch die
sushi bar ist dabei genau in der
obstabteilung arbeitet eine cousine hat
es nicht verstanden dass das wird am
stoff also entschuldigung ich bin
untröstlich ja noch mal wirklich
bezahlen würde ich mir jetzt raus werden
ich bin ruhig die ochsen gemüseabteilung
ist zum beispiel auch ziemlich groß da
bekommt man wirklich ganz viele obst-
und gemüsesorten wie oft hast deine
tabletten wieder mitgenommen heiter
unterricht okay da gibt's autozubehör
spielwaren und zb auch die bücher aufs
klavier alter hast du nicht zugehört
warum ich habe zwei bücher ist schluss
was zu entschuldigen
ich bin untröstlich